you've just been to korea recently yes
how was that amazing was that your first
time yeah oh your first time in korea
yeah i've never been i mean i've never
been i've been far away
you should go well we've never been and
yet it's like an hour and a half because
getting back into japan is such a pain
that yeah it's like if you're going to
leave it better before pretending big
for me like even it was even like before
the pandemic i was like oh yeah you can
do whatever i want and then you never go
and then i just haven't been yet you
guys should for sure plan like two weeks
to go did you go for content or for
vacation and then you're like i can also
make content no i went to stream oh okay
okay okay because i had such a great
time i did this paris trip a couple
years back with jake and we streamed
there it was like that was so much heck
and fun yeah yeah now that we're past
coven will not pass cover days but at
least we can travel more now yeah i just
immediately wanted to plan something
cool and korea was like the perfect
thing i even got to a point i was there
for about 10 days and i got to a point
where i was like i'm having so much fun
should i extend my trip and then i just
kept finding out about other things to
do in korea i'm like i could extend my
trip for three more weeks just come back
yeah but it is just an a plus of a place
to visit what's your favorite thing to
do there
hmm
[Music]
it was the filtered water right it was
the filtered water yeah filtered water
well they have like the best skincare
stuff in the world yeah yeah
like you go to korea
and you come back looking prettier
the clothes the makeup the fried chicken
it's so good yeah i mean the plastic
surgery yeah
none of that
you still look prettier yeah
i remember me and jake i did a 12 hour
stream one day oh my gosh
did you have a battery that lasts that
long he had more than once oh okay and
he had
like eight hours of that with shopping
and that was some of the highest
viewership we had the whole trip what's
wrong people like oh you're going to a
temple you're cooking with a
professional korean chef
you're shopping for 12 hours real [ __ ]
that was the most views well it was like
30 to 35 000
like just
no but the thing is it was growing the
longer we shopped
and i was having the time of my life
were you buying anything or were you
just like window shopping
i don't know what i'm doing for my next
time streaming dude buying [ __ ] on irl
streams is so annoying though because
you have the backpack that's why having
a buddy is great yeah i go pay he's
hiding no credit card leaks no nothing
yeah it was amazing because like you
know
i love to shop now i'm like doing my job
while shopping and other people you're
getting paid to shop you're literally
making money as you spend right now
drugs okay cool but have you ever
shopped while 30 000 people are watching
and that's your job
we're like yo can i get some gifts up
sabotage my shirt
actually the best part of korea was the
fans i've never experienced
such amazing
like
all the fans were amazing and
like the majority of them were girls
awesome
and they always come with a gift
thank you
this one is the requirement to stream
snipe you it's like bring a gift or
don't [ __ ] show up
no
that's why it was so nice i've never
been somewhere where everybody brought
me a gift the whole time
it was just like yeah it just blew my
mind like this one guy came brought me a
gift
and like everyone's so polite and nice
and sweet yeah yeah and he had me sign
something and i sign it and afterwards
he goes
thanks so much
he jumped up and down it was the cutest
[ __ ] i've ever seen
like up and down like that it was
adorable did you have to deal with any
uh people being like no you can't film
in here or anything like that
no oh yeah because korea's chill yeah
korea yeah
japan is quite the poor yeah yeah
unfortunately yeah really that's one of
the things i've over the years started
to hate more and more about la and one
of the like things that makes me want to
leave is that people are so
pressed about whether or not you're
filming you have a filming permit
cameraman oh really people are like that
oh really
yeah because me and lady were in round
one and the moment we stepped out of
round one to go in the mall to do our
intro yeah because it was quieter a dude
immediately came and was like no get
back in the round one really yeah but
run one was chill so see japan is like
that except they'll say it to you in the
nicest way possible yeah yeah they'll
just be like oh sorry no cameras here
you know you're gonna have to go out
because yeah because i've i've been on a
couple of irl streams with rob and you
know he obviously goes like malls and
[ __ ] like that so he constantly gets
people being like sorry you can't film
any or like sorry you can't do it yeah
it's just a matter of like okay we'll
leave it's odd because if you say you're
streaming
sometimes you're like oh okay then but
then recording is like a big no but
streaming is different
because it's just it's recording with
extra stats no you know in japan it's
the weird thing of like you can take
photos but you can't record video yeah
like what's the difference yeah a video
is many yeah
right right luckily the i think the irl
cameras are small so they don't get as
intimidated
if you're carrying around like a dslr
yeah yeah yeah absolutely they get
freaked out yeah in korea not a single
place
oh my god i went shopping in one store
and there was another girl live
streaming a girl try on the clothes i
was like i want to live here
when you say i'm a live streamer that's
what they're going to think fashion
would you ever live in uh korea or any
other country yeah um i think the only
issue
for me is again like time zones time
zone issues yeah i wouldn't know if that
would impact you i'd follow you yeah
they follow you and you get a new
audience as well yeah
start building a new audience i think
but it does kind of feel like starting
over
yeah yeah
and then all these new videos why
pokemane fell the downfall
i'm tired
well yeah i think i think don't you go
for like a month maybe yeah
yeah i feel like you've definitely
established yourself enough where if you
did move to a new time zone people would
just be like okay that's just something
to get used to i think it'd be true
this is why i'm saying if
if you make the content around the
videos because okay let's say i got a
stream right like let's say total 200
000 people watch the whole stream
like quadruple that watch the video
yep
no i think that's like yeah the best way
of content legit i just had to start
realizing like doesn't matter if it's
like a dead time in the stream because
it's all gonna get [ __ ] cut anyway
yeah the video is good yeah because
because you it just completely shifts
your mindset because sometimes you have
a stream that's not doing well like
viewer-wise but you know at least the
video yeah but you know that the thing
is it's going to be a bang of video
you're going to like make that money
back yeah because i i had like uh i had
some of the most viewership i'd ever had
playing alden ring
and
yeah which is i think the opposite for
like most people and i was shocked i was
like wow and but the video said terribly
like no one gave a [ __ ] because this i
don't know if there's just so many album
ring videos yeah yeah yeah things work
better yeah really strange yeah so if
just because it's doing well live
doesn't mean it's gonna lend itself
while it's too well for a video and also
just because it's doing well or not well
for a certain stream it doesn't mean
it's not going to do well for you right
like oh yeah
i've had like i've played a bunch of
like story based games on my streams
where i'm just like no that that doesn't
get viewership
yeah yeah like i remember like my
pokemon rc streams at one point were
doing like better than a lot of other
streams i was doing right like seven
eight streams into it and i'm just like
oh cool i thought i thought this was
gonna suck
yeah it was awesome and then and then i
try and do something else that is like
big for other people and it doesn't
quite do as well for me right so it's
like i've just noticed now not just the
content creator but sometimes the
audience like of course garnered i
prefer certain things yeah absolutely so
that was at that point i was just like
yeah i'm just gonna [ __ ] do whatever
i wanted so some people will just lend
well to certain games and certain
activities and other personalities just
don't yeah exactly absolutely would you
ever want to stream in japan
i already have
and i will again
japan i want to see how well that will
do i bet it's going to do really well
honestly honestly i think it will i
think it'll do i think it'll do
frustratingly
yeah
what i want to do in japan again is just
go to an arcade and play a claw game for
six hours that was like some of the most
fun i had i don't even know why yeah
like you're playing a game but irl but
you can do that but you could do that
here
um no but it's not as exotic if it's not
in japan you know even though it's the
same company it's round one the same
arcades you're playing the same games
you put japan in the title viewers are
gonna watch right not just that but also
um
going to round one would be difficult i
can't i don't stream anywhere in l.a
like i will not do it right unless i can
book out the whole place oh yeah yeah
we're just getting a stream as well
right right a thousand times safer in
korea and japan than i do here yeah
which is sad that's like that's a huge
irl streaming like limitation i i don't
feel safe just walking around with a
backpack alone or even with someone yeah
that goes beyond streaming though right
yeah that's just in general i think
even just visiting here i'm immediately
like i don't feel safe in a lot of
places yeah we did i mean did the round
one stream and that was uh that was that
was okay it was it was the first hour
was fine but then obviously when people
start figuring out where you are and
then it started ramping up because we
weren't we weren't moving around we were
just in round one yeah it was fine
people were really nice though i think
round one attracts a good crowd though
luckily sure but then we're also guys